pop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
après le terrible raz-de-marée qui à la
suite du tremblement de terre du chili a
déferlé sur les rives du pacifique le
japon fait le bilan du désastre
dans les ports de la côte est on
pleurait plus de 100 mains 2000
habitations ont été écrasés par les
vagues et sur les quais où les navires
ont été jetés pêle-mêle on essaie de
sauver ce qui peut être sauvé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le plus terrible raz-de-marée de
l'histoire japonaise
[Musique]
le décollage vertical réservée jusqu'ici
aux hélicoptères n'est pas loin de
gagner les avions les essais réussis
auquel s'est livré le dernier né de
l'aéronautique britanniques semblent le
confirmer
en vo l'horizontale sept appareils à
réaction se comporte comme tous les
autres avions au décollage et à
l'atterrissage ses quatre réacteurs
verticaux lui permettent d'ignorer les
pistes et les aérodromes l'avion de
demain
et demain c'est presque aujourd'hui
[Musique]
au louvre le centre malraux ministre des
affaires culturelles a pu le premier
admirer 700 toiles de maîtres qui
dormait depuis un siècle dans les
réserves
par exemple cette leçon de lecture du
hollandais terre boersch
[Musique]
corps se creuse sept cents toiles sorti
de l'oubli et les réserves du louvre
sont loin d'être épuisées
[Musique]
ce sont des richesses un peu oublié on
vient encore d'exhumer à paris en
illuminant le vieux quartier du marais
les champs elysées du xviiie siècle où
le plan de turgot si tu t'en de demeures
et d'édifices prestigieux
avec un tel sulik occupa le ministre
d'henri iv et dont le portail a été le
témoin de la bastonnade administrés à
voltaire ce sont 18 joyau chargé
d'histoire que la fée électricité a fait
sortir de l'ombre
église saint gervais au style gothique
flamboyant où se maria madame de sévigné
[Musique]
l'at-elle de cuisson construit au 14e
siècle par un connétable de france et où
habitait le cardinal de lorraine et
madame de soubise
mais
l'appel des ambassadeurs de hollande qui
entre autres une pure locataires beau
marché et où il écrivit le mariage de
figaro
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
enfin l'un des plus beaux sans doute
l'ancienne résidence parisienne d
archevêque de sens
l'hôtel de sens auquel restent attachés
les souvenirs de la reine margot que des
vocations tout à coup surgit de la nuit
événement qui viennent en turquie de
rejeter dans le passé le gouvernement
m'intéresse est de porter au pouvoir le
général gürsel ramène l'attention
mondiale sur ce pays où les très
anciennes cités cobistes en volume et
les capitales sorti du néant comme
d'ankara se retrouvent pas rentrer dans
un identique souci de modernisme et
d'extension c'est qu'en moins de 40 ans
ce pays a dû passer du moyen-âge à
l'époque atomique
quelle différence en effet entre c'est
ensemble que l'on retrouve dans les
centres urbains du monde entier et ses
décors d'une vieille turquie désuète et
condamnés
on
mais cette transformation spectaculaire
s'appuie sur des changements plus
profonds
si l'industrie n'est encore qu'un
secteur en croissance il n'en est pas
moins vrai que c'est complexe industriel
ne sont vieux que de 40 ans le saut dans
l'industrialisation n'a d'ailleurs pas à
venir le vieil à un stade de défiance et
la fouille est couramment pratiqué à la
sortie des usines
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
par contre chaque année au cours d'une
sorte de fête de famille les ouvriers
reçoivent solennellement des primes de
rendement avec touchante attention les
compliments affectueux du directeur
c'est là peut-être qu'on peut apercevoir
ce qui est la plus éminente
transformation des structures dans un
pays musulman
l'accession de la femme à la vie sociale
ces ouvriers a complimenté en public
sont en effet les mêmes que ces femmes
voilées dont la vie se passait à l'ombre
des murs de la maison à d'obscurs
besogne sans qualité aujourd'hui la
femme turque mène une vie comparable à
celle de ses compagnes d'occident
gagnant sa vie à l'usiné travaillant en
atelier
délaissant le pittoresque haïk des
héroïnes de pierre loti et s'habillant à
la mode européenne
[Musique]
le modernisme s'est même attaqué à des
problèmes jusqu'ici tenu pour purement
domestiques et familiaux comme la
puériculture abandonnée depuis des
siècles à l'empirisme le plus primitif
la femme a même conquis le droit à
l'instruction qui a vu ses étudiantes
sortant des pour tout pareille à leurs
soeurs de france ou d'amérique peut
constater à quel point la structure de
la vie turque a changé ne peut on même
dire que dans ce domaine la turquie est
allé plus loin que d'autres nations
un petit fait permettra de conclure les
escadrille de chasseurs à réaction
comptent dans leurs rangs des officiers
pilotes féminins qui au milieu de leurs
compagnons masculins accomplissent la
même tâche difficile et suivent les
mêmes disciplines la turquie l'arriéré
d'hier est peut être aujourd'hui le seul
pays au monde à offrir ce spectacle
étonnant et nous pouvons penser que la
turquie n'est pas au bout de sa
métamorphose est que à la suite de la
nouvelle orientation
elle va faire un nouveau pas dans le
monde
pervis dobson 181e édition la course la
plus importante de la saison hippique 17
chevaux départ deux cent cinquante mille
spectateurs entassés tout au long du
parcours et la famille royale c'est une
tradition dans la tribune présidentielle
[Musique]
cette année une série de malheur s'est
abattu sur le derby qui s'est terminé en
tragédie
le cheval français angers le grand
favori de l'épreuve qui est encore dans
le peloton en ce moment dans les faits
ce brisé une jambe il sera abattu
immédiatement
[Musique]
angers n'est plus là maintenant la
course se déroule sans lui et la lutte
est très sévère sur une piste
extrêmement dur qui fatiguent chevaux et
jockeys
c'est un poulain anglais sympathique qui
se dégage dans la dernière ligne droite
et qui prend trois longueurs à tous ses
concurrents il rapporte ainsi 45
millions à son propriétaire
[Musique]
indianapolis le grand prix automobile le
plus spectaculaire du monde chaque année
on y ramasse sur une civière une bonne
demi douzaine de pilotes
c'est vrai qu'on roule à plus de 200 à
l'heure et qu'on ne se fait aucune
concession sur la piste
[Musique]
voilà ça commence miracle le pilote est
indemne cette année c'est dans les
tribunes que se produit le drame
une échelle métallique s'effondre 30
personnes sont précipités sur le sol
affolement général on ne s'occupe plus
de la course l'échelle s'est écrasé sur
d'autres spectateurs de morts 50 blessés
et
[Musique]
pendant ce temps les voitures continuent
de tourner sur la piste et s'est rappelé
anne qui gagnent l'épreuve à plus de 220
de moyens
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]